let's bring in Chris Mannix Yahoo Sports
senior NBA writer did the Celtics see
this coming Chris that Kyrie Irving was
a possibility of missing the rest of the
season no I don't believe they did Dan
look you go back to last summer and
there was some thought within the
organization based on what they knew
from Cleveland perhaps higher vine would
need some kind of cleanup procedure at
some point to address you know the
screws that are in that knee the wire
that's in that knee but they believed
he'd be able to play through it and it
was until that pain got completely
intolerable that they had to go this is
now twice surgically repaired root but
this this the significant procedure came
as a major surprise to them that the
bacterial infection that he's dealt what
he's dealing with in there that was not
something they saw coming handicap these
playoffs no no you know I've watched a
lot of Toronto and maybe more than most
and I'm buying the Raptors I think the
Raptors are the favored here and I know
they got beat twice by Cleveland but
they're an entirely different team when
they play on their home floor they've
only lost seven times at home Dan and
and you look at some of those young guys
the bench guys the Fred van bleats and
the Pascal Jakob get heralded guys they
play a lot better on that home floor now
there's there's a mental block with
Toronto when it comes to LeBron and if
they lose Game one in a conference model
to Cleveland all bets are off there but
right now because of Cleveland's defense
because the margin for error for them is
so small given the talent on their
roster because as we sit here with a
week to go in the season they're still
changing their starting lineup I'm just
not believing the Cavs contender in the
East this year
LeBron you have any chance win the MVP I
guess he has a chance but is there any
chance that he will her best chance that
he'll win this no the Washington Post a
couple of months ago did a straw poll
among voters I'm one of them and James
Harden won the landslide and he'll look
LeBron is having maybe his best
offensive season and and what he did
watch him last night the last four
minutes of the game is a test
and to all that but James Harden I think
has only had two months this year where
he has an average 30 points per game the
Rockets are the best team in the West
and they have I think still a top 10
defense it's gonna be I just think it's
impossible for the Brawn to overcome
that I'm gonna vote for James Harden I
think it's gonna be a lot it's gonna be
almost a landslide it I understand it
it's James Harden's time but I think
LeBron James is having one of the best
years of his career and certainly it has
been a year though Dan that's my
question for you is it a two way year
because I've seen him and I was at a
couple of games live in the last month
he's playing
I mean mediocre defense doesn't even
cover it harden doesn't play defense
it doesn't matter James Harden is not a
defensive team though that team is a top
10 ish defensive team this year that has
to be factored into all this yeah but
he's not playing defense on a defensive
minded team they helped him out
so LeBron has got to do everything on
his team who helps out LeBron here James
Harden gets home no you're right James
Harden has the best defensive cast
around him but I think James Harden is
trying defensively and I can't say the
same for LeBron for a large part of the
game yeah I mean look watch these games
the first three quarters I'm saying this
I don't blame him at all because of the
burden he has to take on offensively yes
he should manage his body throughout the
course of a game
but if you're talking MPP if he was a
two-way player this year I would vote
for him this year he's not yeah but I
can't give James Harden credit because
of the defense he doesn't play but his
team does but I'm gonna hold that
against me wrong defense team defense is
the thing I mean I'm not saying that
James Harden is this you know part of
this connective tissue that creates this
this defensive climate in in Houston but
team defense is a thing they're not
winning games you know or they're not
good defensive teams just because Clint
capela blocked shots or because lukla
Babu they get stopped there's a
defensive element here and I think you
have to give hardened some credit for
that alright let's say both God heard in
November for the year which team has a
better record now Houston or Cleveland
Houston does more talent yeah I I don't
know the Cleveland make the playoffs yes
that makes my point you had I'm not
saying it's not I'm not saying he's not
a consensus number to e or Dan but the
point is like neither one of them has
been hurt for a month so we don't have
that kind of we can't I don't think we
should ask that hypothetical when voting
for the MVP you're not voting on the
best player in the league you're voting
on the guy that's had the most valuable
season and James Hart to me is that
clearly where is LeBron next season
I mean look one thing we can be sure of
is that when we discuss this in October
November there will be something
revealed about whether it's a plan in
place or something he and player X had
talked about it R asking me the smartest
place for him to go it's still
Philadelphia I mean it just is you know
LeBron goes to Philadelphia he fits in
right away
he becomes the Alpha of that team and he
can age gracefully because over the next
five six years as the bronze game
inevitably at some point winds down he
is going to have guys around him that
can step into bigger roles and allow him
to be a second third fourth type of
option on that team that makes the most
sense I don't have any idea where he
ultimately winds up it's in his head but
it feels like Philadelphia and I
remember bringing it up on the air and
and it hadn't gone public
I don't think and then all of a sudden I
said you know why why would he go west
when he could stay east and you have
this talent there and I know him and Ben
Simmons might be kind of handling and
playing the same position here but you
want to get back to the Eastern
Conference Finals you're gonna have to
go through Boston and Toronto again but
I'm thinking what about Portland's young
talent is it would there be any chance
with Portland with LeBron yes I think
you know Portland
you remember Daniel Shay was the GM of
the Clippers when they got a meeting
with LeBron back in 2010 and that was
when the Clippers were for a mess and so
I think Niall O'Shea being there and the
team he's put together is going to make
them an attractive piece the Portland
has had trouble recruiting guys in the
past rumor Carmelo wouldn't even
consider a trade there you know when he
was you know thinking about waving his
no-trade clause so I think it
possible but I don't look at them as a
front-runner there's gonna be some
tanking here in like how bad is this
typically how bad is this going to get
with tanking here in the final week I
mean it's been as bad as I've ever seen
it over the last few weeks like what
kind of gravitas does the NBA have at
this point where you know they ordered
the Bulls to play Robin Lopez the Bulls
said okay
they played him for like one game and
then sat them out again and then I mean
Marc Gasol you know if they're Grizzlies
build a lead Marcus all comes out like
that's that's where they're at with all
this Sacramento same thing there are
some there's some game stand that over
the next few where five or five days I'm
just gonna hate watch I'm gonna hate to
see what happens like Grizzlies Mavs I
think that's end of the season I think
Grizzlies Kings is in tonight this is
this is probably the most egregious
example of tanking that we have ever
seen when you consider the number of
teams as many as eight that are brazenly
tanking who is trained a tank worthy
here that is their one player that you
go you know this Bagley or Aten are they
tank worthy yeah teams tell me at this
point and and we have the Portsmouth
camp next week and the combine after
that so things change but teams tell me
that Aidan has kind of emerged as a
consensus number one a guy that
eventually could be a monster on the
boards like a almost a Drummond type on
the boards but also can shoot the three
they like him a lot but this is a raft
and we're three four five
we could see franchise players that's
how high a lot of people are on this
draft and that's why it as tanking has
been so bad I asked this question to
Doug Gottlieb if I said Grayson Allen
Trey young or Dante D Vincenzo who's
your better pro I think very young and
it's not just got the height you know
people a lot of people kind of zoned in
on him from like mid-december on and
even now those the reports back on him
are still really good now he really
struggled towards the end but I mean he
had to carry that pain down I may put
them on his shoulders I think Trey young
is a lottery pick and the best player
for three
I like the Gottlieb said Trey young is
going to get a coach fire
it's an interesting quote might get a GM
fired if you wind up taking him it kind
of simmer rains and there's three four
guys behind him that get that are better
and getting the wind up on those teams
thank you Chris good to talk to you
again have a good weekend Dan guy I just
like the opportunity though quick
quickly bring to your attention
Rubio's candidacy for Most Improved
Player let me give you up to ten seconds
here so as you know really always been
arguably an NBA's best player since the
all-star break his score had jumped some
teams his three-point shot once
foolishly believed to be an Achilles
heel has become a weapon for him and
that's it I gave him 10 seconds I might
have given him 11 there for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]